so there was definitely just an
earthquake right now
my second day in LA and finally after
all this time of a sunny California
I witnessed my first earthquake
it's actually kind of shaking right now
and oh my head it was really scary
because I'm kind of high up here in this
hotel
it wasn't really sure what to do I don't
know the proper earthquake procedures
do I believe we hang out do I jump off
this ledge here I don't know I don't
know what are the proper earthquake
procedures to a Google that I guess
maybe I probably would've had time Wow
that was seriously really scary I wish
that I could've grabbed my camera and
time to show you the everything that was
kind of moving around on my desk
now
Wow don't with nature